Years after the peak of his visibility, Tony
Hawk is still around.
At 50, one might think he's slowing down a
bit, easing into a quiet retirement perhaps.
In fact, Hawk is as busy as ever with philanthropy,
conquering the fashion world, and much more.
For a huge swath of kids, teenagers, and savvy
adults at the dawn of the new millennium,
Tony Hawk defined what it meant to be awesome.
"What I want people to think of me?
I guess I want them to think I'm just like
them.
Which I basically am."
But today, the man behind the board is as
much into his family as he is into the half-pipe.
His son Riley Hawk was born of his first marriage
in 1992.
"I think at first people thought it was kind
of strange that I was kind of doing the skate
thing too."
Two more boys, Spencer and Keegan, were born
of his second marriage, and his first daughter,
Kadence Clover, was born in 2008.
Tony Hawk married once again in 2015 and now
lives comfortably in California.
Hawk might be older now, but his love of skating
pervades his home life.
His eldest son Riley has become a celebrated
skateboarder in his own right on his 21st
birthday, Riley went pro and won the Best
Am award within minutes.
Today, he's sponsored by Baker Skateboards
and has become respected as a street-style
skater, in contrast to his father, one of
the most celebrated vert-style skaters of
all time.
Kadence also pops up regularly on Hawk's Twitter
and Instagram channels, learning the basics
from the world's most accomplished teacher.
Tony Hawk has become increasingly involved
in charitable work over the years.
In 2002, he created the Tony Hawk Foundation,
an organization that facilitates the building
of public skateparks across the United States.
Focusing specifically on the needs of low-income
and otherwise disenfranchised areas, the foundation
has awarded $7.9 million dollars in funds
to date.
The breadth of the mission is startling.
Every part of the country has been marked
by Hawk's quest to make skating accessible,
respected, and safe in all communities.
Recently, Hawk spearheaded a campaign to take
the foundation global with a $50,000 grant
to Skateistan, an organization that works
to bring skating to Cambodia, Afghanistan,
and South Africa.
In 2015, Hawk told ABC 10 News:
"Skateboarding's empowering women in Afghanistan,”
“more than probably any other sport, to
be honest."
In 2007, Hawk helped found Athletes for Hope,
which fosters connections between the world
of elite sports and young hopefuls.
More than ten years later, they're still going
strong.
Hawk has been a hot commodity in the entertainment
world for decades.
Over the years, he's played himself on The
Simpsons, appeared in kiddie fare like Rocket
Power, and taken bit roles in action flicks
like Deck Dogz.
Oh, and don't forget his cameo in the 2005
film Lords of Dogtown, where he played an
astronaut who wipes out on his skateboard.
More recently, Hawk popped up on the popular
YouTube hit Epic Meal Time and he even made
an appearance on Sesame Street back in 2008:
"How many wheels on a skateboard?"
"Four wheels on a skateboard."
"Can you count 'em for me?"
Also, we would be remiss to mention his star
turn in The Aquabats!
Super Show!
"Aquabats, what was it like being thrown into
outer space?"
"We were in outer space?"
Skate culture has been influencing the fashion
world for a long time.
From Avril Lavigne's stylings in the early
2000s to the classic Vans Off The Wall sneakers,
skating and fashion have always seemed to
go hand in hand.
It was only a matter of time before an actual
skater took that relationship to the next
level.
Tony Hawk did this with the Tony Hawk Signature
Line, a collection he debuted at Paris Fashion
Week.
The line is an upscale take on skater style,
as envisioned by one of the skating subculture's
most legendary heroes.
Talking to Vogue, Hawk weighed in on the success
of streetwear brands like Palace and Supreme,
noting how they're now being
"... recognized and embraced by a much bigger
crowd.
People who want to have that look but who
don't necessarily skate."
In 2019, he told Highsnobiety:
"If we've reached that level, I want to join
in, too, 'cuz I feel like I have enough to
offer and I have enough history."
Hawk's career coincided with the rise of the
internet, so it makes sense that he would
jump head-first into the world of original
video content.
"This is my first skateboard ever and we are
sending it today to the Smithsonian.
And I thought I would give it one last try."
Enter the RIDE channel, Hawk's own little
corner of YouTube, which he launched in 2011.
Here, you can immerse yourself in all things
skating and skate culture.
As Hawk says in the welcome video:
"We're super excited.
This is something that we've always wanted
to do and it's finally a reality and it's
here on YouTube and you should go subscribe
right now."
RIDE has a dizzying lineup of programs.
There's Concrete Dreams, a documentary web-series
about the challenges of skatepark advocacy.
And there's lots of nitty-gritty reviews for
the latest skating gear.
"If you prefer, like, a slimmer shoe that
you don't have to hold like this, then you
probably shouldn't get these."
What makes the channel so great?
It's not about the cool factor; it's about
the reality of the sport.
"We're gonna learn some stuff here and check
out the session and then I'm gonna kick everyone
out."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.